Another Thing Dr. Bright Is Not Allowed To
Do At The SCP Foundation: Challenge anyone
to a duel and then give them SCP-572.
Challenging other Foundation personnel to
a duel is a terrible idea at the best of times
- That’s how we lost Dr. Hamilton - but
it becomes especially farcical with SCP-572.
572 is a shoddy and poorly weighted katana
that, to anyone using it, appears to be a
blade of awesome power, that drives them to
perform ill-considered and dangerous stunts.
These often result in the injury of themselves
or others until the sword is taken from them,
or they’re knocked out.
It causes major headaches for the Foundation
whenever it’s used, but of course, Dr. Bright
thinks it’s hi-larious.